what is the cancellation
sphere that that's out there in the
world at the moment
well the clear one that does exist is
the attempt
to find people whose employment
is vulnerable to mob stampeding
so you know somebody says something on
twitter for instance
uh in support of uh somebody that
twitter doesn't like
and their twitter then finds where they
work
and uh you know lobbies their boss until
they're sacked something that that's
that's
that's the aim and there's lots of sort
of versions of that
um lobby a company uh pretend that you
know the company's
to lose masses of money because just
destroyed its market you know
capability because everyone's unhappy
with it um
that stuff does go on um
but you're not happy with that being
called cancel culture well no no no
it's not that i what i'm what i'm
worried about is that we get stuck
on it um because
i believe it's much more important to
focus on what is
winning and what winning looks like
and you know there is a certain you
notice this in american journalism a bit
more than you do here there is a bit of
oh
i was so nearly canceled oh i was
cancelled
there's a sort of certain you know
you always have it in writing because
writers are a very self-obsessed bunch
and and tend to think of themselves as
being brave i mean
you know mark stein made a famous quip
years ago you know like
writers are forever giving each other
awards for bravery and you know you
don't
all of the professions where they're you
know like you've got to run into burning
buildings and save people
they're like they don't spend all their
time talking about bravery awards you
know
but but writers are very big on bravery
and writers like quite a lot of writers
like the idea that they're sort of
you know edgy and and all that sort of
thing and so they say the idea of being
cancelled a little bit you know
for them i don't really care about that
stuff i i care about people saying what
they think
and i'm really i really think that
people
should not pay so much attention to a
very very rarefied and demented
minority of people and i don't think we
should give these people the right to
dictate the cultural weather in any way
in any way why should
a small demented group of people who
believe
that the big bearded man with a penis is
a woman if he says he is
that they should dictate the cultural
weather across the country
and make major authors have to fear for
their careers
and make all politicians become
gibbering wrecks
when the subject comes up why should
that be the case
why can't we just have discussions out
in a reasonable fashion
and you know advance your case the best
of your capability but you don't do that
i think we've given in issue after issue
very
deranged minorities minorities of
minorities
the right to basically dictate the
weather and and we don't need to
because on any estimation on any
estimation
you know most of those people are not
doing that well
you know the authors who are the
anti-rolling people are not doing as
well as her
so why not you know why not say actually
the person the point about this is is to
say
the person in your life you should want
to be is jk rowling not just because you
should want to be rich but because you
should want to be in a position in your
life where you can tell the truth
that should be the position you aim for
and i'm worried that all of this sort of
actually encourages people to say
the position i would like to sort of
hold in my life will be the one where
nobody notices me and nobody comes for
me and i sort of get away with it and
then die
how vanilla can i spend the remainder of
my life i'd like to be
somewhere in between the color eggplant
and beige
absolutely on the on the great color
chart of humanity
human experience and that's but that's
what that's what that's what they're
doing and i i just
i think we should encourage people not
not to play that game
it's hard right if you've hit on
something there that
people like yourself or sam harris or jk
rowling
by virtue of uh success or financial
backing
or a level of independence with regards
to your platform or whatever it might be
have taken great got in great lengths uh
to make yourself uncounselable
but not everyone has that luxury sure no
no i don't i don't underestimate it at
all
um i just my experience in life is that
i've always said what i think
and uh it's worked well not done you
that's that's the thing i said before
our first podcast like
how do we get through all of these
topics without stepping on a landmine
and you increasingly just sort of do a a
ballerina dance through this land yeah
back and forth
to think it's slightly more butch than
that but but i agree it's something like
it's somewhere in that yeah yeah a newer
af like leaps around like that that's
what you're
that was the image that was in your mind
i've got this image of you in a pink
tutu that's just dancing through a
minefield but that's
we're too close here now i'm just
thrilled that the image is in your mind
[Laughter]
but but no i mean i uh yeah that's my
experience
um it is not to say that it's completely
easy
i mean you know you you have to do your
work and you have to
work hard you have to you know weigh
your words and you speak them as when
you write them but you you know any
normal person would anyway
and um but yeah i i i just i think we've
got to change the um
you know there's this thing that's gone
on in our era in general
i think it's came out last time that
that we've moved from the heroic
mood in the society to the victim mood
you know we've moved in general from the
who is the person who's been most heroic
in their lives to the sort of
celebration of whoever's
can say they've been the most victimized
and this is all a little bit of that
it's a little offshoot of it and i'm not
really that interested
in victimhood not because i'm um
hard-hearted or anything like that it's
just that my observation of life
is that we can all of us whinge
endlessly if we want to
about our lot because human experience
is extraordinary in lots of ways and
will always include an awful lot of
mundanity and pain and grief
and much much more so
we could all do it um
i'm just not sure that our society
should encourage it as much as it does i
think you're right there's an
interesting
translation uh change that i came across
recently
um the buddha said life is suffering but
the word of suffering
is duca duka and as with all ancient
translations it's
a nearest closest term that they try to
find right
and suffering was one of the
translations but there's some scholars
that contest that it's not
suffering it's unsatisfactoriness life
is
unsatisfactoriness and if you spend a
lot of time in evolutionary psychology
you realize
that that unsatisfactoriness is fitness
enhancing if you were
yes absolutely fully actualized upon
killing your first bison you'd never
kill another bison
upon having sex the first time you'd
never have sex again
exactly i i do know people like that
but the come on
no you're right look at the unsatisf
with
the accretion of wealth uh never get
enough of it um
it's not the best way to do it uh but
it's it's one thing yes
unsatisfiedness is is isn't an entirely
bad thing um
it's an enormous drive for a lot of
people
um it's it's obviously one of the things
behind ambition
and and yes i i think there's a there's
there's an awful lot of things going on
in our age but we we should
try to identify the things that we are
erroneously holding up as good
and i do think i do think that holding
up victimhood is
as not just good but meaning that you
especially deserve a platform or a
microphone
has turned out to be a an unhelpful
way to start a new generation off in
this world it's a jordan petersonism
right where he talks about the fact that
uh a rabbit isn't inherently good
because it's unable to commit evil
it's the enacting your shadow fully
fully internalizing your shadow from the
jungian perspective
um and the same with that like you you
very correct there is no bravery
in avoiding courageous challenges
right um and and one of the things uh
again i really touched on this we last
met but one of the things i'm
particularly worried about in this era
is what's happening to men
in all of this because men seem to me
the primary people at the moment who
have been persuaded
to lessen their capabilities lessen
the things they could achieve and sort
of
just find a way to get through this
strange
period that we're in and and it's it's
not healthy it's not healthy for men
it's not healthy for women
um it makes very unhappy men
and it makes they unhappy women because
women don't want those men
you